ja ich möchte es einfach mal teil und
zwar bin ich der festen überzeugung dass
wir aufhören sollen die maske zu tragen
nicht nur weil ich finde dass bei den
aktuellen umfragen und genesenen raten
es nicht mehr nötig ist sondern vor
allem auch der umwelt zuliebe denn alle
sprechen immer darüber dass wir aufhören
sein fleisch zu essen wir sollen nicht
mehr auto fahren aber auch dass maske
tragen es nicht gut für unsere umwelt
ein beispiel die maske wenn man mit
einem vw diese eineinhalb kilometer
fährt hat man genauso viel co2
ausgestoßen wie machst du einmal trägt
und da wir alle fast nur noch einen weg
masken tragen also die op masken und die
ffw zwei masten ist also pro masken
gebraucht ein halber kilometer mit einem
vw diesel in beiden fällen sind das 50
gramm dazu kommen nach das recycling
problem ich meine das jetzt hier
natürlich schon mit einem augenzwinkern
aber ich bin dafür weg mit der maske der
umwelt